Settle down, settle down.
This is not some other class,
this is 3.091. So, I have an
important announcement.
There won't be a lecture next
Wednesday. Instead,
there will be another celebration of
learning. You're going to come,
and you're going to show us what
you've learned.
It's going to be so festive.
And, I want to make sure we are all
celebrating the same thing.
I meant to patch in.
It didn't get it patched in.
I apologize. So, let me tell you
what it is. We're going to look at
is the lectures of starting with
lecture 17, which was on x-rays.
And, halfway through that lecture
was the break point for the last
test. So, we will start with the
material beginning with Bragg's law.
We didn't talk about diffraction on
the last test.
The coverage talked about
generation of x-rays,
but not their use in diffraction.
So, starting with x-ray diffraction
up through the end of last day's
lecture. And,
the reason I'm doing this is that
tomorrow is a holiday.
There are no academic exercises
tomorrow. And so,
I didn't think it made a good
pedagogical sense to teach you
something today and have no
recitation on Thursday.
You don't meet again with your
recitation instructor until Tuesday
and then Wednesday's the test.
So, being mindful of that,
I'm going to start talking about
solutions today.
None of that will be on the test.
So, starting with x-ray diffraction
and ending with diffusion,
so as I've got up here, we saw
Fick's laws, first and second laws,
error function, all that stuff will
be fair game. And of course,
we won't have a test, a weekly quiz,
on Tuesday. We'll have plenty to
work on for Wednesday.
So, let's leave it that way.
So, last day, we completed the
discussion of diffusion,
going through analytical
presentation of Fick's laws,
and how they're used in a
quantitative measure of rate
phenomena in diffusion.
Today what I want to do is
introduce another topic from the
general realm of physical chemistry.
And, this is the topic of solutions.
And, for that,
I'm going to go all the way back to
the very first lecture in 3.
91 when we looked at this figure
from the text.
And, what we've been doing up until
now is largely working over in the
lower left corner of this taxonomy.
We've been looking at the
properties of elements.
We've looked at a few compounds,
but we really haven't gotten up into
here. Everything has been pure
pretty much. But,
we have had to make the odd foray.
What we talked about glasses, we
got into the discussion of solutions
because we were talking about how
you can modify the properties and
tailor the properties by changing
composition of a glass.
So, that was really in this domain
of mixtures. And we talked about
doping of semiconductors.
When we dope a semiconductor we
actually put phosphorus or boron
substitutionally for silicon.
So, in essence, we are making a
solution. So that's all up in here.
But, I'm a little bit uncomfortable
with this broad definition of
mixtures. So,
I've taken the liberty of refining
that somewhat.
And so, what I would prefer you
recognize is that there is
two types of mixtures.
There's homogeneous mixtures and
heterogeneous mixtures.
So, homogeneous mixtures are what
we would call solutions.
And, that gives you mixing right
down at the molecular level,
whereas heterogeneous mixtures are
not mixed down to the molecular
level. They are mixed down to the
level of clusters of molecules.
So, for example,
if I look at something like brine,
brine is salt dissolved in water.
It's visually uniform.
We cannot tell that there's more
than one component.
And, it's this homogeneity
uniformity that makes it a solution,
whereas if you look at something
like milk, milk is a mixture.
It's an aggregate. Milk actually
consists of two phases: there's a
fatty phase which is insoluble,
and the aqueous phase.
And, what's happened is we've got a
fine dispersion of the second phase
in the first phase.
And that fine dispersion floats.
The fat is clear and colorless, and
the aqueous phase is clear and
colorless. But that dispersion
scatters light.
And that's where we get the white
in milk. And,
I don't like the notion that whether
it's milky or clear and colorless,
in other words, coarsely mixed or
finely mixed; we simply
lump them under.
So, I'm going to be talking today
about solutions and making sure that
we understand the underlying
chemistry. So,
you might say, well,
we signed up for solid-state
chemistry. Why is he talking about
solutions? Well,
I'm going to give you three reasons.
First of all, we have many systems
that we're looking at are solutions.
It's very rare to use pure
substances in engineering
applications. So,
we need to understand solutions from
that standpoint as we've learned how
to tailor the properties of glasses,
how to tailor the properties of
semiconductors,
metal alloys, and so on.
Secondly, many materials are
processed out of solution.
The way we make fine powders is not
to make little molds and cast liquid
into tiny, tiny little molds.
We make fine powders typically by
precipitation out of solution.
So, we need to understand the laws
that govern dissolution,
and exsolution, precipitation.
And thirdly, one of the major units
that we're going to cover before the
end of the semester involves
biochemistry. And,
the environment for most of
biochemicals is a wet environment.
So, I think it's requisite that we
know something about that
wet environment.
So, that's sort of the background
preamble. And so,
what I want to do today is introduce
some definitions.
So, we'll breeze through some
material on the handouts,
and ultimately get to the
miscibility rules.
That's what we really want.
We want to know that miscibility
rules, the rules that govern what to
substances or three or more
substances are going to mix and form
solutions. So,
that's what we are heading to:
miscibility rules.
And then, finally,
we're going to do some quantitative
calculations by the end of the class.
So, let's get on to the handout.
On the one side, we've got the
types of solutions.
So I'll just quickly go through and
get these definitions under our
belts. A solution consists of at
least two substances.
The majority substance is termed the
solvent. And then,
the minority substance,
and there can be more than one,
is the solute. So, you can have a
plurality of solutes,
but you have one solvent.
So I just want to make you
understand that solutions are not
simply aqueous solutions.
Solutions span all of chemistry.
So, let's go down this chart that's
been organized according
to state of aggregation.
So, first case we've got a solid
solute and a liquid solvent.
Brine is a good example of that.
You've got solid sodium chloride
dissolving in liquid water.
Here's liquid-liquid. This is wine,
which can be broken down as ethyl
alcohol dissolving in water.
All right, and we can dissolve a
gas in a liquid.
And, seltzer is an example where we
have carbon dioxide dissolved in
water. And, I mean,
it's chemically dissolved in the
water. It's under high pressure.
When you release the pressure,
you see the bubbles exsolve. But
when we say solution,
we are talking about something that
is mixed at the molecular level.
So, this is solvated carbon dioxide.
So, now, let's use a gas as the
solvent. There's only the one case
there: gas dissolving in a gas.
So, we could say that air is a
variety of gases dissolved in
nitrogen as the solvent.
Nitrogen is the majority species,
about 80% nitrogen.
We have oxygen.
We have argon. We have carbon
dioxide. If we're living next to an
aluminum smelter,
we probably have some
tetrafluoromethane.
If you've lived next to a power
plant, burning coal,
you've probably got some sulfur
dioxide, and so on and so forth.
So, this is a multi-component
solution. Now,
let's look at solids.
This is 3.091, so how about some
solid solutions?
We've seen evidence of those
already. Solid metal alloy: carbon
dissolved in iron.
The carbon goes in interstitially,
mixing at the molecular level right
down to the atomic level here.
We've looked at semiconductors,
boron going into silicon. Boron
sits on a silicon site,
and actually bonds into that
framework. We looked at stabilized
ceramics where we put calcia into
zirconia at the end of the last
lecture to make a high mobility
oxide ion conductor that would act
as a sensor for automotive
applications.
And then, we looked at putting
modifiers into network formers.
We form a solution. So, these are
solid solutions.
And then lastly,
we can look at putting liquid into
solid, which is the primary example,
is mercury going into silver. It's
an amalgam. This is now past
history, but certainly in my
lifetime for a while I was walking
around with a number of these
amalgams in the shape of
fillings in my mouth.
These were very conveniently made
right in the dentist's office.
But, people have come to appreciate
that it would be a good idea not to
have mercury in your mouth because
over time it does leach out a little
bit. And we know it's not conducive
to good physical well-being.
So, this is now thanks to advances
in materials science,
been replaced by some advanced fine
ceramics that can function
in place of this alloy.
And lastly, we can put gas in solid.
This one is topical today. As
people think about a hydrogen
economy and how we're going to put
hydrogen on automobiles,
one way is to put compressed
hydrogen tanks full of compressed
hydrogen at about 5 to 10,
00 psi. That's not very appealing.
Another approach is to interpolate
hydrogen into a compound that can
dissolve large quantities of
hydrogen. And this is
one such compound.
So, this is a solution of hydrogen
dissolved in lanthanum nickel five.
So, that's the range of
possibilities of solutions.
And then, I want to look at a
little bit more detail here in the
fine structure of mixtures.
And, in the case of mixtures,
we can look at the solution as being
something that's mixed at the
molecular level where,
say, the diameter, if you will,
the diameter of the solute is down
less than several nanometers.
So, we are effectively looking at a
homogeneous solution.
I've mentioned brine.
And, there are simple tests that we
can put to this.
First of all, it's visually uniform.
And, in fact,
it's transparent to visible light
because of the band gap that it
presents. But the main thing is
that it's visually uniform.
It's impossible to filter. If we
wanted to separate sodium chloride,
if we wanted to desalinate, we
couldn't do so by filtering because
the filter would have to be at the
subatomic level in order to trap
something at the atomic level.
Well, that's absurd.
So, you can't separate solution by
filtration. And lastly,
it will not settle out. If you make
a solution of sodium chloride and
water and let it sit in a gravity
field, it's not going to stratify
because it's mixed at the atomic
level. But, these two here,
the colloid and the suspension,
are the heterogeneous type.
They are aggregates because they are
mixed at the cluster level.
And, depending on what the particle
size is, we end up with two
conditions, and I want you to be
aware of these because there is some
interesting physics involved.
And, what we're talking about here
is dispersions.
It's a dispersion because we don't
have homogeneity.
Dispersion is fine particles.
And I'm using the term particle to
mean this cluster,
fine particles distributed
throughout some matrix.
And, what's the principle behind
this? Why doesn't everything just
settle out? Well,
here's what's going on.
When we look at a foreign particle,
this is this cluster that's on the
order of 2 to beyond even 1,000 nm.
And, why is this suspended in
solution in the first place?
Because we know we've got two
forces acting on it.
First of all, we've got a gravity
force, which is acting to cause this
to settle. So,
this is a settling force thanks to
the gravity field.
And, working in the other direction,
this interface between the insoluble
and the solvent,
along that interface we have binding
forces as well.
And these binding forces I'll
simply call interfacial forces.
And, these interfacial forces want
to bind the particle to the solvent
at the resistance to
the gravity field.
So, now, why does particle size come
in to play? You know the gravity
force is proportional to mass.
And, the mass of the particle is
proportional to the volume of the
particle. And volume scales with
the cube of the radius,
whereas this interfacial force,
as the term implies, interface, the
interfacial force is proportional to
the area of contact between the
particle and the solvent.
And, area scales as the square of
the radius. And you know from your
math that R cubed dominates R
squared when R is large.
That comes as no surprise.
But, at very, very small values of
R, R squared dominates R cubed.
And, depending on what the relative
forces are is going to govern what
the relative particle size has to be
before we get particles that will be
suspended in the second phase.
And so, we have here the example of
the colloids. One example of the
colloid is milk,
which I described to you already.
And even though we have two phases,
both transparent to visible light,
that interface scatters the light.
These particles are large enough
that they can be separated
by filtration.
But it's unlikely that they'll
separate in a gravity field owing to
this. They don't settle.
They don't settle. Actually,
what has happened over the past two
generations is a shift in the
particle size of the fatty phase of
milk. When you go to the store
today, you buy this red cap milk
called homogenized milk.
Well, go back two generations ago.
There was no homogenized milk.
Milk was simply pasteurized
and sent out.
And the particle size was so great
in the fat globules that after
several hours the fat would coalesce
and rise to the surface.
So, you'd have a creamy phase on
top. And people would take that out
and use it in their coffee.
And then you'd have what's
effectively skim milk on the bottom.
So, somebody came up with the idea,
obviously somebody who had studied
the rudiments of physical chemistry,
and reasoned that if the fatty phase
could be broken down to a finer
particle size,
then the buoyancy forces would
dominate the gravity forces and it
wouldn't separate.
So, homogenized milk is simply milk
in which the fatty phase has been
reduced in cluster size to value so
small that by the time the gravity
field is able to dominate the
buoyancy field,
the product is spoiled anyway.
So, for the practical shelf life of
the product, you don't have to deal
with starting by taking the milk out
of the fridge and shaking it in
order to get good mixing.
That's a good example.
In the case of something like blood,
the cluster size is far too large
for that to happen,
and so it's not homogeneous under
illumination. It's easy to filter,
and it will separate in a gravity
field. So, what we're seeing here
is a demonstration of the
competition between the
gravitational forces and
the interfacial forces.
And, the interfacial forces are a
function of the kinds of bonds that
form. So, it's all there.
It's all there. And, lastly,
this colloid, I want you to be aware
of the definitions here.
I'm not going to quiz you on this.
I simply want you to have it so
that at some point you might want to
go back and refer to it.
I'm not going to test your memory.
But this breaks down the entire
taxonomy of colloids where we see
that there's a difference between
what happens in the liquid
dispersive medium,
a gas dispersive medium,
and a solid dispersive medium.
And, you can see many of the common
products that we know are in fact
these dual phase mixtures that
involve very, very fine particles on
the order of some hundreds of
nanometers that we use in common
products. So, so much
for the taxonomy.
But now I want to turn to the
question of miscibility.
And, in order to do that,
I want you to consider this example,
which I've actually taken from your
reading. I want to look at
dissolution of substances in a
liquid bilayer.
So, we're going to put two vessels
side-by-side, and each will contain
the same liquid bilayer.
And, the liquid bilayer is going to
consist of the bottom layer in both
vessels is carbon tetrachloride.
And the upper layer is water. And,
first of all, let's ask why these
don't mix. They're both liquid at
room temperature.
Why don't they mix?
Well, let's take a look at the
electronic structure and bonding.
Whenever I ask why, you know,
you've got a test coming up a week
from now. When I ask why,
try to work something into the
answer that speaks to electronic
structure because that's the clue.
So, what do we know about carbon
tetrachloride?
It's nonpolar,
so why does one carbon tetrachloride
bond to another carbon tetrachloride?
And, please don't tell me something
to do with the electronegativity
difference between carbon and
chlorine. Let's forget about that.
It's nonpolar, so all we've got is
weak van der Waals forces.
So, we have a van der Waals liquid
on the bottom whose density
is about 1.4.
So, it's going to lie under water.
And water, on the other hand, in
contrast to being nonpolar,
it's polar. And it has hydrogen
bonding capability.
So, these are very different
substances. And they don't have the
capacity to link to one another.
And so, they don't. They choose
forces of cohesion over
forces of adhesion.
And so, we have two separate layers.
So now, we're going to ask, what
happens if we introduce a candidate
solute? So, we really have a
bilayer of solvents.
And now, we're going to introduce a
solute. In the one case,
we're going to put in solid
crystalline iodine.
In the other case, we'll put in
solid crystalline potassium
permanganate. And why do we choose
these? Well, first of all,
they're both solids, solid going
into liquid. And,
secondly, they're both purple,
very important.
They're both purple.
What happens is if we drop iodine
into this bilayer,
stir vigorously, mix everything up,
and then wait. The two liquids will
phase separate in a gravity field,
and then we'll find at the end of
the experiment that we have a
solution here of iodine carbon
tetrachloride solution mixed at the
molecular level.
On the other side,
shake vigorously, wait for system to
equilibrate, layers phase separate.
And now, here we have a solution of
potassium permanganate in water.
We can see with the naked eye, the
upper layer is purple.
The lower layer is clear and
colorless. In this case,
the upper layer is clear and
colorless. The lower layer is
purple. So, it's clear that iodine
has strong affinity for carbon
tetrachloride.
Potassium permanganate has a strong
affinity for water.
So, what's going on?
Well, let's look at the structure
of the candidate solute.
What's iodine? Iodine is a
diatomic molecule.
And it's nonpolar symmetric.
So, it's a van der Waals solid.
And, the van der Waals solid
dissolves in a van der Waals liquid
because together they've got
fluctuating dipole interactions that
can allow them to bond to one
another and form a solution,
whereas with water it's less favored.
In this case, potassium permanganate
is an ionic compound that forms
potassium cations,
and permanganate anions.
And so, we have an ionic solid
dissolving in a polar liquid.
So, the polar liquid is able to
attract the positive end of the
dipole attracts the anion.
And the negative end of the dipole
attracts the cation.
If you read the typical chemistry
textbooks, they don't go into such
an elaborate discussion.
They like to simplify it to a
slogan, a tagline.
So, you will see this.
Well, I hope you don't see that.
I hope you see it's spelled
correctly. You will see
like dissolves like.
I look at that and I said it's too
simplistic. And I'm going to give
you some examples of where that
doesn't happen.
Besides, I mean,
I look at that and I wonder if I'm
reading something from California.
The like dissolves a like.
[LAUGHTER] Tenure means never having
to say you're sorry, so just
enjoy it. Enjoy it.
So now, what I want you to do is to
look at this table.
This table is going to show that
this is not such a smart tag like to
work with. Again,
I will not expect you to commit this
table to memory.
I would never ask you to tell me
what the solubility of something is
by heart. I would,
instead, turn around and say,
for example, calcium copper bromide
forms aqueous solutions.
And then, let's take it from there.
I tell you what the fact is. But
what I want you to notice first of
all is that the table is broken into
two regimes, soluble ionic compounds
and insoluble ionic compounds.
So it's not so simple. There's
something else going on here.
And, let's take a look. There's
one they say, for example,
the chlorides are generally soluble.
And the oxides are generally not
soluble.
So, what do we have to think about?
Well, it's a competition, really.
It's a competition.
When we look at sodium chloride,
it exists as a solid crystal. And
now, we have to compare whether it
wants to go into aqueous solution.
And, what we see is that the answer
here is, yes, whereas the answer for
magnesium oxide,
which is also an ionic crystal,
it does not form aqueous solutions.
So, what's going on here?
Well, what's the major difference
here? Sodium chloride exists as
sodium cations and chloride anions,
whereas magnesium is divalent. So,
we have magnesium cations
and oxide anions.
And in the crystal lattice,
we have a much, much higher crystal
lattice energy for magnesium oxide.
If you just go through the Madelung
derivation, you will have double,
double. So, it's, in essence four
times. And sure enough,
the melting point of sodium chloride
is about 800í melting point,
whereas the melting point of
magnesium oxide is about 2,
00í. And, what happens when we try
to make this dissolve in solution is
something that looks like this.
Here's a cartoon showing water
dissolving sodium chloride.
So, sodium chloride, just to get
oriented, the green spheres
represent the chloride ions,
and the blue spheres represent
sodium ions. And,
just to keep things current,
you can see up here one, two,
three, four, five, the face of an
FCC Bravais lattice,
but we've got two atoms per lattice
point as our basis,
etc., etc. And, here's the water
molecule, which looks sort of like
Mickey Mouse here with the red
showing the oxygen,
and the white showing the hydrogen.
So, the oxygen end is the negative
end of the dipole.
And, what the cartoon showing is
that the negative end of the dipole
is presenting itself to the cation.
And, if the attractive force
between the solute and the solvent
exceeds the binding energy,
the crystal binding energy, we will
have dissolution.
And that's borne out here where you
see that we have a difference in
Coulombic force of attraction that
makes it accessible for sodium
chloride for water to dissolve it,
but inaccessible for magnesium oxide
because the forces are too strong.
And then, you see the complement
here, that the positive end of the
dipole is presenting itself to the
chloride anion.
I'm always amused when people draw
ions colored because I know they're
trying to color code them,
but think about it. If you could
isolate a chloride ion,
what color do you think it would be?
There's an answer to that question.
What's its electronic structure?
See, it always goes back to
electronic structure.
What's its electronic structure?
It's isoelectronic with argon. And
what you think the color of argon is?
What do you think the color of any
noble gas is? So,
actually, these things should all be
clear and colorless.
I just wanted to point that out.
I know they're color-coded for your
amusement, but I was staring at this
green ion, and asking myself,
should ions be green? No, no,
they shouldn't. OK, so now let's
talk about measures of solubility.
I'm going to put some numbers on
this. So, we can express solubility
in the following units.
There are a variety of units,
but the only one that we really need
to worry about is the molar quantity,
which represents moles of solute
divided by liters of solution.
And, remember, the solution is the
sum of all solutes plus the solvent.
All solutes plus the solvent
constitute the solution.
And so, moles per liter,
when we say sodium chloride
dissolves at so many moles per liter,
we can abbreviate that by uppercase
M, which we term molar.
So if I have a one molar solution of
sodium chloride and water,
one molar is equivalent to,
say, one mole of NaCl, in one liter
of solution. I was about
to write water.
It's not. It's 1 L of solution
total. And, here,
I think, you can see that it's not
an all or nothing situation.
In other words, certain substances
are insoluble for reasons we've seen.
But, other substances are soluble
up to a point.
You know from experience you can
add sugar to water,
and a dissolves very readily up to a
certain value,
beyond which you can add the sugar,
stir it, shake it, do whatever you
want, but the sugar will not
dissolve beyond a certain limit
which we call the solubility limit.
Or, in aqueous systems,
they simply call it the solubility
and, at this limit,
we've reached a condition termed
saturation. We say the solution is
saturated with respect to the solute,
and can take no more.
And, there are two measures for
saturation solubility.
One is just denoted C star,
or some people use C sub S, which
means the concentration of solute at
saturation. And that's a simple way
of getting it.
And, it works when all we are
dealing with is one solute
in one solvent.
But, to make matters richer,
so that we can treat conditions
where we have more than one solute,
the other approach is to use a term
known as solubility product.
And, the solubility product is best
shown by example.
Let's look at a salt that dissolves
in water but very sparingly:
silver chloride.
Silver chloride has a lattice energy
that's low enough that we can get
some to dissolve in water but only
sparingly so. And so,
I'm going to put an equal sign if we
move from left to right.
We're dissolving, so let's call
that reaction dissolution.
And, when we move from right to
left, that's called precipitation.
And so, silver chloride dissociates.
It dissociates to form silver
cations. And,
to show that they are dissolved in
water, I'm going to write aq,
meaning it's in aqueous solution,
and the chloride anions, again, aq.
And, this notion that when an ionic
solid dissolves in water,
it dissolves not as a molecule of
silver chloride,
but rather as cation and anion was
in fact what won Arrhenius
his Nobel prize.
He got his Nobel prize not for,
I think, his really good work on
activation energies and so on that
paved the way for our understanding
of catalysis, and so on.
He got his Nobel Prize for this,
which was called the theory of
electrolytic dissociation,
meaning that when an ionic solid
dissolves, it forms an electrolyte,
that is to say, an ionic conductor.
So, that was his Nobel prize.
And, what we do is we can express
the solubility of silver chloride by
the solubility product denoted Ksp
as the product of the instant
concentration of each of the ions.
And, I know at first blush you are
going to say, well,
that's just the same as talking
about the concentration of the salt
dissolved. And,
that is the case in this trivial
example. We'll move on to something
a little more sophisticated in a
moment. So, I'm going to take the
concentration using square brackets
to denote concentration.
So, it's the product of the
concentration of the silver cation,
and the concentration of the
chloride anion.
And, concentrations here are in
units of moles per liter.
So, I'll plug in the value of the
silver ion concentration and the
chloride ion concentration.
And that gives me the solubility
product. And then,
this goes up to some master value.
And, that's the saturation. So now,
I want to show you that we have some
evidence for this.
So, here's some evidence.
What I'm showing you is a plot of
conductivity, the conductivity of
the solution as a function of the
number of moles of silver chloride
that has been added.
And, what you see? First of all,
here we have the conductivity of
pure water. Pure water is a very,
very poor conductor. We should
really properly call it an insulator.
And, in units of,
this is reciprocal ohm,
which is the Siemen. In units of
Siemens per centimeter,
the conductivity of pure water is
less than ten to the minus seven.
It's some number times ten to the
minus eight Siemens per centimeter.
So, what's happening? When we
dissolve silver chloride,
we are adding, this is the same as
doping. We are adding charge
carriers, only instead of adding
holes to the valence band,
or electrons to the conduction band,
that's not going to help us because
water isn't a metal.
Water is capable of dissolving ions.
So, we're going to make it an ionic
conductor by injecting carriers.
The more silver chloride we dissolve,
the greater the number of carriers.
The greater the number of carriers,
the greater the conductivity. So,
by measuring conductivity as a
function of concentration,
we can determine if we are
dissolving the silver chloride,
as opposed to we keep adding it and
it just sinks to the bottom.
So, let's look here. What we find
is as we add silver chloride,
the conductivity of the solution
rises up to a maximum value at
around ten to the minus five moles
of silver chloride per
liter of solution.
So, that would be a concentration of
10 to the minus five molar.
And then, what happens? We keep
adding silver chloride,
but the conductivity doesn't change.
So, what do you think is happening
if you could stare at the beaker?
You could see the silver chloride
just falling to the bottom.
So, the knee in the curve indicates
that we've reached saturation
solubility. So that's good.
So, we have evidence to support.
Now, we can then compare the
solubility with the solubility
product in the following manner.
We can say that the relationship
between the saturation solubility is
really equal to the concentration of
silver chloride dissolved,
which Arrhenius has told us is
really the concentration of silver
ion, which is equal to the
concentration of chloride ion.
All of these are the same.
And so, with a little bit of
algebra, we can show them that the
relationship between this and Ksp is
- since the concentration of silver
equals the concentration of chloride,
then we can take Ksp to the one half
will then equal the C star,
the saturation solubility. And,
for silver chloride, it turns out
that the product,
the solubility product,
is 1.8 times ten to the minus ten,
which then means that the saturation
solubility for silver chloride is
the square root of that,
which is about 1.3 times ten to the
minus five.
And, sure enough,
that's what you see on this plot.
You see that somewhere just a
little bit higher than ten to the
minus five molar,
the plot has flattened out.
But now, let's look at the more
interesting case and put the
solubility product to work and ask
ourselves, what happens if we add
silver chloride not to pure water,
but to a solution that contains
already some other dissolved salt.
Is that going to have an impact on
the amount of silver chloride we can
dissolve? So,
let's give a specific example,
and a specific example is add silver
chloride to a solution already
containing sodium chloride.
I'm going to add silver chloride to
a solution of 0.1 molar NaCl.
So, I already have chloride ion
present. See,
this is interesting.
If I said that, instead of adding
silver chloride to pure water,
I'm going to add silver chloride to
water that already contains some
silver chloride,
you say, well, that's obvious.
If it contains some silver chloride,
I can't put as much in as I
otherwise could.
But now I'm going to say,
it's not silver chloride. It's
sodium chloride.
Does the presence of sodium
chloride have any impact on the
dissolution of silver chloride?
So, again, we'll look Arrhenius'
theory of electrolytic dissociation.
So, silver chloride will dissociate
and go into solution as silver
cation and chloride anion.
And, sodium chloride is present as
sodium ion and chloride ion.
So, we've got now, note here
multiple sources of chloride ion.
We're getting some chloride ion
from silver chloride,
and we get some chloride ion from
sodium chloride.
So, the consequence of that is that
I know I can no longer assume that
the concentration of silver ion
equals the concentration of chloride
ion. That's no longer the case
because I've got some chloride ion
that came from sodium chloride.
So, that's a problem. That's a
problem. So, what do I do?
I'm going to try to find the
saturation solubility of silver
chloride under these
new circumstances.
So, I'm going to go back to my
solubility product,
Ksp. And, Ksp is going to equal the
product of the silver ion
concentration times the
concentration of the chloride ion.
And, I can take a stab at what this
is. I told that this is on the
order of 0.1 molar.
And, we saw that in the case of
pure silver chloride,
it's ten to the minus five molar.
It's about four orders of magnitude
lower even when we have
full dissociation here.
So, I'm going to assume that ten to
the minus one molar is so much
greater than ten to the minus five
molar, which is what we got in pure
silver chloride that I'm going to
neglect the contribution of chloride
ion from silver chloride,
and say that the concentration of
chloride ion is simply equal to 0.
because 0.1 is so much greater than
what is left over from the
previous calculation.
And now, I can still make the
connection between the dissolution
of silver chloride salt,
and the concentration of silver ion.
That still exists as one to one.
So, this will then represent C of
silver chloride times 0.
. And, that's equal to this 1.
times ten to the minus, what is it,
ten to the minus ten.
So, I can solve for the
concentration of silver chloride,
and that gives me 1.8 times ten to
the minus nine molar.
So, the presence of the chloride
from sodium has had a tremendous
repressive effect on the dissolution
of silver chloride.
This is called the common ion effect
because I have a common ion from
both solutes, and one influences the
solubility of the other: common ion
effect. And, we can use the common
ion effect to our advantage.
If I want to process something in
order to cause precipitation of very,
very fine particles,
I can load a solution with one
solute, introduce a second solute,
and trigger the precipitation, and
in doing so, control particle size,
and the shape, and thereby prepare a
material for subsequent processing.
In fact, you can use this.
If you want to determine if you've
got water that's been chlorinated,
simple thing you can do: if you go
back to that table 8.
, you'll know that silver nitrate
has a very, very high solubility in
water. So, I introduce silver
nitrate into water,
and the question is,
is there any chlorine present?
And, if there's any chlorine present,
we know that the saturation
solubility of silver chloride is ten
to the minus five molar.
What will happen is if you've got
chlorinated water,
and you add silver nitrate,
you will see a shower of very,
very fine, white powder, which is
the silver chloride.
So, this is a very good test for
residual chlorination.
So, now how can we use some of this?
Let's take a look. I've got two
things I want to show you.
First of all, one thing going back
to the last lecture dealing with
diffusion, and I want to show how
diffusion is important in forming
bonds if we want to make coatings.
So, here's a carefully drawn
cartoon by your professor to pose
the question, suppose we want to put
a coating of A on a substrate,
C, and they don't stick.
They don't stick very well.
So, one strategy to enable the
binding of coating A on substrate C
is to find a substance,
B, such that A will bind to B,
and B will bind to C. This is
called an interlayer.
And, it's used commonly in the
industry when the coating won't
stick to the native substrate.
So we use an interlayer.
So, here's a product where this is
used on a regular basis.
I don't own stock in Gillette.
I just happen to know that there's
a ton of materials science that went
into the design of a product as
mundane as a safety razor.
So, I want to look at the blade.
It turns out, they wanted to cut
the blade with a substance called
diamond like carbon.
Diamond like carbon is a mix of sp3
hybridized carbon and sp2 hybridized
carbon. It's not a diamond film.
I want you saying that Professor
Sadoway said that the Mach 3 razor
has a diamond film on it.
It doesn't. If it did, it would
cost more than it does now.
And it's exorbitantly expensive as
it is. So, it's sp3 and sp2.
It's a mix. And, this material is
very, very hard.
It's very hard. You want something
that's hard to give you the
resistance to keep
that cutting edge.
But you don't want to meet the whole
blade out of something like that.
Otherwise, it will be brittle, and
it will shatter.
So, you want the composite material.
So, it turns out that diamond like
carbon, if you put it on steel,
since the blade is made of steel,
there is very poor adhesion. And,
Gillette was determined to get
diamond like carbon on the blade.
So, they asked, what could be an
interlayer?
And they tried many different
substances, and finally settled upon
niobium. They went to a fairly
exotic part of the periodic table.
They used niobium. It turns out
that niobium, niobium as you know is
a body centered cubic metal.
And so, it can interdiffuse with
steel and form a bond here.
And, the other thing is that
niobium is an element that has a
very high propensity
to form carbides.
So, niobium forms an interdiffusion
bond with the steel,
and on the free surface has a
carbide which then is capable of
bonding to the diamond like carbon,
and thereby giving us the bond that
we need. And the last thing I want
to show you is something that I just
saw this morning.
I was getting ready to go.
Tom, could we shift to the document
camera? I want to show you how we
can take diffusion to make products.
Perfect, OK, this is a ceramic knife.
It's made of zirconia.
It's made of zirconia. Now,
how do you suppose they make this
knife? How is this knife
manufactured? You start with
zirconia. This stuff melts at 2,
00 degrees centigrade.
Can you imagine?
It's an ionic compound.
So, it has no ductility.
And please don't tell me because of
dislocations; it has no ductility
because the bonds are so strong.
The only way you could perform
zirconia would be to push,
push, push, and then it breaks.
So, you can't make a billet of
zirconia the way they do how they
make a steel knife.
They make a billet of steel,
and then they, by mechanical working,
they reduce the thickness,
and then eventually sharpen the edge.
You can't do this with this material.
So, what do they do?
They use solid-state diffusion
starting with particles of zirconia,
fine particles which are compressed,
raised to elevated temperature on
the order of about 1,
00 degrees Celsius, and held there
for several days.
And, during that time,
diffusion takes place to reduce the
void space, bringing this
to near 100% density.
So, the vast majority of fine
ceramics that you see in the
marketplace, I'm talking true
ceramics now, not the glassy stuff.
Pyrex, yes, Pyrex is castable. But
not this. This is all processed by
solid-state diffusion,
a process of agglomeration known as
sintering. Sintering is
consolidation by solid-state
diffusion. And then,
in the end, with the diamond wheel,
the edge is cut. And, this stuff
has a mho hardness of 8.
, making it second only to diamond,
which has a hardness of ten.
High corrosion resistance,
no metallic flavor, very sharp,
and it holds its edge, made by solid
state diffusion. OK, we'll
see you on Friday.